[Music]
Quadra hello
you guys requested new defenders they
drop new defenders so guess who's back
let's break this down Elektra is coming
back it's going to be so awesome so
because I have to explain all about
daredevil season 2 an iron fist just to
explain the different factions of the
hand a lot of you been asking me about
that what's the difference between the
different versions just careful for
spoilers from iron fist there's a lot of
ideas that cross over but there are
different fingers of the hand that I'll
explain different factions between
daredevil defenders and iron fists
there's actually three different
factions we've seen so far but there's a
new round of the Marvel giveaway I'm
actually doing guardians of the galaxy
ticket giveaways all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video I'll announce a new winner
at the end of this - but if you're
wondering why they've released this
teaser of all things like obviously we
expected Elektra to come back at some
point because of all the resurrection
that was happening during daredevil
season 2 but it's been about a year
since that show ended so what an
appropriate anniversary to bring her
back but in the comics she had been
killed by bullseye and was later brought
back to life by the hand so this is all
from the comics even though they change
a lot of things about the way the hand
works the way they portray them on the
different TV shows so you start out with
a no booze faction that's the first
version of the hand that we see we see
him come back to life we learned through
Styx character that he's done it many
times in the past so each time you see
him pop up like after season 1 he comes
back during season 2 his face is a
little more scarred up and at the end of
season 2 he chops his head off just to
be sure
stay dead this time so they're always
really mysterious about how long lives
people are because stick is part of the
chase there's this ancient order that
sort of weaves into some of the ideas
that they teased during Iron Fist with
the capital cities of heaven so it gets
a little confusing when we get into iron
fist stuff because the chase is a very
different organization but the TV show
might choose to combine them so there
might be some overlap because they're
talking about the ward that is coming
this big mystical war it all through
iron fist he says he is the immortal
enemy of the hand so it got a little
crazy but Elektra is very important to
Nobu's faction of the hand because all
the factions of the hand worship a demon
called Gorgon and it made it sound like
Elektra was going to be the spirit of
this
Demon's resurrected in human form like
they talked about black sky during
season one so you have the different
factions of the hand that all seemingly
have different goals you have the zombie
hand with Nobu that we see resurrect
people like we see the zombies fighting
that's how Claire temple got kicked out
of her Hospital but then you have Madame
Gao faction of the hand that are
peddling the drugs didn't see as many of
the undead hand during iron fist and
then she sort of has a power struggle
with Baku doz version of the hand which
is a little bit different they're more
like the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
faction of the hand they find little
kids on the street take them in and turn
them into warriors so even though
they're not the undead soldiers that you
saw fighting for Nobu you get the undead
storyline through Harold Meacham's
character so they still find a way to
remind you about how it works and what
things look like when people come back
from the dead just preparing you for
this Elektra moment we learned that
Madame Gao separate faction of the hand
wanted to take control of Rand
enterprises they go to Harold Meacham
and he's totally happy to make a deal
with them he has a terminal form of
cancer he has a little while to live so
Madame Gao brings him back to life but
they still have to pretend like he's
dead but during the Iron Fist season we
see Harold Meacham die a couple
different times and come back each time
he comes back he gets a little bit
crazier as if there's less and less of
him that comes back from wherever he was
when he was dead the spirit world
whatever you want to call it we then
learned through bakudo 's character
who's a separate faction who sort of
gets rid of Madame Gao puts her on ice
and says look we're much more
businesslike we want to make a deal with
you Danny ran but he explains to Harold
Meacham that the gift of life that they
give to people is something that's very
special and it's something that they can
take away so that's sort of the
resurrection on the show so when you see
Harold Meacham sort of stumbling around
like Frankenstein mmm this is good that
was probably one of the worst parts of
the show it's just a way of showing you
what it's like after someone first comes
back from the dead what that applies is
that when Elektra climbs out of this
she's going to be super crazy at least
for a little while in bakudo even sees
that there was another member of the
hand it was very anxious to work with
the iron fist so because defenders is
next that might be the Alexandra
Sigourney Weaver character who could be
the leader of another faction of the
hand so five fingers of the hand make up
fists
so there are three that we met so far
the noble hand implied that they were
there to serve Elektra they worshipped
her kind of like a goddess so she might
be one of the new leaders of the hand as
well let me know what you think about it
easier than bringing Elektra back and
what you want them to do for the
storyline during defenders if you're a
big comic book fan and you want to read
along Marvel is doing a new version of
the defenders comic book written by
Bendis that's based on the Marvel
Netflix lineup so the Marvel Netflix
characters will be getting their own
comic book but I don't think it's going
to be a tie-in with the series but the
first issues dropping June 14th the
first episode of defenders are really
all the episodes are dropping August
18th
so the comic is dropping a couple months
before the actual series drops just to
get you ready for it but what can happen
next is is I have my new flash episodes
I'll post there's Avengers infinity war
behind the scenes Robert Downey jr.
posted a video for a charity thing
there's a couple behind-the-scenes shots
I'll do a breakdown of that too I have
new stranger things season 2 as well so
I'll try to post it all as fast as
possible but congratulations to the
latest Marvel giveaway winner Juan
Rosales
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait but at
the post you can click here for brand
new flash and you can click here for
that other defenders teaser thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you